you know it's easy to get the idea that
the city of Boston has lost maybe its
creative spark a little bit this is the
place that once brought America a lot of
Firsts the first public park the first
subway system the first tea party the
first massacre and so on but now
whenever you hear Boston in the news
it's usually pretty uninspiring stuff by
comparison uh you're hearing about the
mayor and how the mayor is Banning white
people from holiday parties or the fact
that the president of Harvard has never
had an original thought in her life or
the decision by Mass General to bring
back mask mandates you know stuff like
that despite all that it would still be
a mistake to say that uh Boston has
given up on Innovation you know they
they're still doing pretty
groundbreaking stuff up there at least
if you ask them so for example back in
2019 suffk County uh Massachusetts which
includes the city of Boston embarked on
a a first ofit kind real life social
experiment under the leadership of their
new district attorney Rachel Rollins
suffa County decided to stop Prosecuting
criminals who were accused of most
nonviolent misdemeanors including
disorderly conduct and shoplifting and
the cops would you know arrest the
shoplifters and the prosecutors would
just let them off the hook and this was
a this was a relatively new strategy for
a major American city at the time
because remember this was before the
racial Reckoning of 2020 as they called
it the theory was that the that you know
these kinds of prosecutions did more
harm than good and it's better to refer
the criminals to you know counseling
sessions instead of throwing them in
prison
disincentives the idea that a negative
response to a certain Behavior will
result in less of that behavior is a
basic rule of psychology and one of the
most tried and true facts of life but
the city of Boston decided to reject
everything we knew about human
psychology and human behavior in favor
of this new
strategy well how did that work out a
few years after that policy went into
effect leading researchers at major
universities including ruers Texas A&M
NYU published a lengthy paper declaring
that in fact Boston's strategy had been
a major success they found that quote
the recent policy change in suffi County
imposing a presumption of
non-prosecution for non-violent
misdemeanor offenses decrease the
likelihood of subsequent criminal
justice involvement in other words if
you let criminals get away with
shoplifting they're less likely to get
in trouble with the law in the future
and in leftwing circles this is known as
restorative justice and officials in
Boston said it was proof that their idea
had worked success what no one seemed to
grasp at these universities is that this
is the exact result you would expect
when you legalize shoplifting and it's
not a good result like it's not
surprising that shoplifters don't get in
trouble with the law anymore if you stop
Prosecuting them for petty crimes if you
don't punish people for crimes fewer
people will be punished for crimes it's
like like if you if you stopped all
cancer screenings then claim that cancer
had been cured because no one's getting
diagnosed with it
anymore the point is that Boston didn't
stop people from shoplifting and
committing Petty crimes in fact of
anything when you do this it means
people will be shoplifting a lot more
because why wouldn't they if they can
get away with it then more people will
do it and indeed they're they're going
to shoplift so much that it becomes
impossible for businesses to stay open
which means that very quickly so-called
disadvantaged community
will lose access to convenience stores
Andes they'll become even more
disadvantaged which is supposedly the
opposite of restorative justice you're
not restoring anything whatsoever and we
don't have to speculate about this all
we have to do is look at what's
happening right now in Boston Walgreens
has just announced that it's closing its
fourth location in Boston in just the
past year four locations closed in just
a year and um every single time it's
been a lowincome community mostly Black
Or Hispanic that has been affected and
this this time they're closing a store
in the mostly uh black neighborhood of
rockberry now you might think that this
development would prompt some Reflection
from the media in Boston or uh from the
politicians or from activists in the
local community you might think that
they'd ask whether allowing people to
Rob stores is in fact you know maybe a
bad idea but that's not what's happening
instead we're getting reports like this
one from CBS Boston listen the store
shelves are empty and the signs are up
alerting customers at this Roxbury
Walgreens will be closed for Good at the
end of the month how do they supposed to
go get their medicine it's sparking
concern and outrage from residents who
rely on the Warren Street drugstore in
this predominantly black neighborhood
what happens to our seniors and our
single parents that have no way to get
to a Walgreens or another Pharmacy
anywhere near their home and so we think
it's insensitive it's unjust Reverend
Minard Co pepper points to the senior
housing developments just Steps From the
Walgreens and questions how the elderly
will get their medications especially
after the pharmacy chain closed their
stores in Hyde Park Nubian square and
matapan about a year ago Walgreen says
they're downsizing but the Reverend
calls it nothing short of corporate
greed why do you think they target black
and brown communities I think because
they get no push back but they're now
getting pushed back protesting alongside
dozens of other frustrated customers
fighting to keep this Walgreens open
don't we need to have something in the
community to help the black the elderly
the sick you know what I'm saying they
can't go far the problem boils down to
accessibility says former Boston NAACP
president turned Healthcare Advocate
Michael Curry the communities where
they're closing these pharmacies are
communities where people are uh
desperately impacted by disease you know
two or three times higher rates in
cancer diabetes heart disease we're life
expected can be 15 20 years less while
this isn't the only Walgreens or
Pharmacy chain set to close location in
the coming weeks Curry says it begs this
question what is your
obligation what is your expectation as a
corporate citizen to do what's right for
those communities Beyond what's right
just for your bottom line well you know
that question is uh pretty easy to
answer Walgreens just like every other
private business has no obligation to
lose money
they don't have to stay open to provide
any kind of service to the local
community they're not soup kitchens
these are not charitable organizations
their job is to make money that's not
greed it's called economics it's called
reality a business like Walgreens can't
stay open if it's losing money it just
can't that's why it's the government's
job to make sure that there's Law and
Order so that thugs don't just walk into
Walgreens and take everything and end up
shutting these stores down but there's
no sense anywhere in that entire segment
that Boston's policy of encouraging
shoplifting might be to blame you can go
online and watch the whole clip and if
you want and see for yourself it's just
not there they don't even they don't
mention it you they essentially legalize
shoplifting uh convenience stores were
sarily run out of town and the media
doesn't even mention the connection
between these two events there's also no
sense that Boston's recent decision to
defund its Police Department could be
playing a role uh instead we're left
with the implication that Walgreens just
doesn't like black people
the argument appears to be that
Walgreens should should keep its
business open as a
charity um where it keeps bleeding money
in order to provide various services to
the local community but if you do some
digging it's not hard to conclude why
Walgreens is shutting down this
rockberry location here for example is
footage taken by a citizen journalist in
Boston a couple years ago he films as
police finally arrest a woman they
caught shoplifting three separate times
in one one day now watch this to get a
sense of what it's like at these uh
Walgreens locations in that area and
what they're dealing with here it
is5 the last the last one I wrote then I
wrote another one on
shoplifting I still got the stuff in the
book Hey sir sir talk to please sir
please
I
please this is just
ridiculous shoplifting is a big thing
over here too just so you guys know it's
a it's a big problem I know I problem I
see especially when it's the same person
I know trust me I see it and then they
want three times today I got reps that I
wrote last week same same person three
times wow a even other people right she
comes in here try to give her good nice
and let her out try to be nice
well three times in one day they saying
that she uh she did
like yeah you know so that's that's the
problem a lot of these business are
losing a lot of Revenue because of the
shoplifting thing and a lot of people
don't realize that if you go to some of
these shelves especially in the Roxberry
area some parts of doorchester as well
the lot of shelves are becoming empty
because of shoplifting I heard the Auto
Zones having that same problem with
people shoplifting in the
stores so it's not like they're making
it up it's definitely a problem this is
right over at the uh
Walgreens right on Washington
Street so this is how common shoplifting
became in Roxberry and the surrounding
areas after Boston's big push to
legalize shoplifting uh the comps you
know don't arrest the shoplifters
anymore for the most part they released
this woman several times before
arresting her out of
exasperation and when they finally feel
compelled to make an arrest everyone
knows it doesn't matter the shoplifters
know that they're not going to be
prosecuted so they keep on coming back
that woman will be you know ripping off
stores uh again probably within a few
hours and that's why Walgreens is now
shutting down all these stories in
Boston this is a a a massive problem as
the cops say in that video according to
one study shoplifting in Boston is up
roughly 40% since June of 2019 when the
city's experiment began and in the city
overall okay in neighborhoods like
Roxberry the figures are presumably a
lot higher and it's not just shoplifting
that's out of control recently the
Boston Globe ran a story that was
intended to portray Boston or rather
portray Walgreens in a bad light and
make them seem like an evil greedy Mega
Corp for closing the rockberry location
but they included this information in
their report quote the generational
impact is felt by rockbury residents
like Lucille C pepper Jones she doesn't
see herself visiting the Columbus Avenue
drugstore a mile away because she
doesn't feel safe walking there
alone so this is a neighborhood that's
so dangerous that elderly woman women
don't want to go outside and yet we're
expected to believe that businesses
should stay open in these kinds of
neighborhoods where their stores will
get robbed their employees will get
attacked people aren't safe outside of
the store or in it it would seem and
that's just an assumption that CBS and
NAACP demand that you make
so naturally they're telling everybody
to protest Walgreens instead of the
politicians that CBS and NAACP support
who have caused this problem now of
course um protesting Walgreen's decision
to pull out of this neighborhood it's
it's a bit like protesting the laws of
gravity you can whine all you want but
basic economic principles still
exist businesses exist to make a profit
and when they can't make a profit they
have to close down even if they don't
want to and most businesses don't want
to close locations it's not something
that they celebrate doing but if they do
it it's probably because they had no
choice and yet the other day the
residents of Roxberry uh decided to
gather together to protest anyway and no
they were not protesting shoplifting
they were not protesting the politicians
Who legalized it they were not
protesting their own community members
who are victimizing these businesses and
running them out of town no instead they
were of course protesting Walgreens
itself watch so this w greens is
critical not just to this community but
the surrounding communities and the
seniors Walgreens is downsizing
Nationwide telling us quote when faced
with the difficult decision to close a
location several factors are taken into
account including our existing footprint
of stores dynamics of the local market
and changes in the buying habits of our
patients and customers among other
reasons but after sitting in the parking
lot observing for hours I can tell you
this location has a consistent stream of
customers and sits next to a dialysis
center as 300 people from Harvard Street
Health Center that comes to this
Walgreens in our community that's
elderly that's um parents this group
says they'll continue to Rally until
Walgreens changes their mind in Roxbury
I'm Tiffany Chan WBZ News now we should
point out CVS also announced that it's
closing pharmacies inside Target stores
CVS says the closures will begin in
February so next month and will be
completing in April we do not have a
list of those pharmacies yet but we're
told there will be dozens
Nationwide so CBS does some
investigative reporting in that segment
um by which I mean their reporter sat in
the parking lot for a little while and
noticed a steady stream of customers at
the
Walgreens and we're apparently supposed
to conclude from this that the store is
doing fine and has no reason to close I
mean they saw people going in and so
that must mean everything I mean how
could a business be doing poorly if
there are people going inside of
it but the problem with uh you know
shoplifting is that it's not that nobody
goes in the store it's that too many
people go in the store and then don't
pay that's that's the issue you know
it's generally difficult to shoplift
without physically entering the store
I'm sure criminals are working on a
solution to that problem I guess you
could do like online scams and that sort
of thing but generally speaking like if
you want to shoplift an item that's on
the the the the rack at a certain store
you have to go in and do it or you have
to send someone else it does require a
physical presence in the store but the
reporter cannot explore that Avenue so
uh instead they just decide that it must
be racist never mind of course that the
racism Theory here makes no sense
whatsoever I mean leave aside everything
we know about the shoplifting problem
like what is the claim exactly that
Walgreens is actually making money at
that location and everything is fine but
they're closing down anyway and Cho
choosing to lose money just to spite
black people like is that actually what
we're
suggesting did the Walgreens CEO at some
uh corporate meeting say shut down that
location Roxberry shut it down and
somebody on the executive team said but
sir they're turning huge profits their
profits are up 25% in the last year I
don't care I don't want black people in
my store shut it down like is that the
theory do you think that's what's
happening the theory is that Walgreens
would rather close down a store then
provide services to black people if
that's the case you'll have to explain I
don't know literally every other
Walgreens location in the country that's
still open considering they all provide
services to large numbers of black
people which is why you might argue that
of the two possible explanations racism
or shoplifting the shoplifting one makes
a lot more sense but in fact in their
own statement Walgreens itself couldn't
really blame shoplifting either they had
to give some coded language of about
marketing uh market dynamics and so
forth and that's a contrast to what we
saw last year when
Target uh shut down nine stores
including its store on fulam Street in
San Francisco and one location in Harlem
and in that that instance Target
explicitly blamed quote theft and
organized retail crime which are
threatening the safety of our team and
guests and contributing to unsustainable
business
performance now after Target made that
decision various left-wing Publications
including CNBC attacked Target they they
rushed to point out that Target was
closing stores with relatively low
reports of shoplifting compared to
stores that Target was leaving open and
from this Daya point we were supposed to
conclude that Target uh was racist now
I'm not one to defend Target and I don't
really care if the whole uh company is
shut down um and it should be but for
entirely different reasons you know for
the reasons of like sexualizing kids and
all the degenerate disgusting stuff that
they sell but you know the racism charge
of course is entirely absurd like one of
of the problems with this analysis is
that stores where shoplifting is common
don't report it so that led to a comical
moment for example 2021 when a single
Target store decided to start reporting
shoplifting incidents and that doubled
the entire City's shoplifting rate in
the month of SE an entire month one day
of shop of of uh of of reporting uh or
rather one store reporting shoplifting
incidents doubled the the rate for the
entire city um which which shows you
that prior to this they just weren't
reporting it so once again the startling
math works out the same if you don't
report something then you will end up
with fewer reports about the stuff you
are not reporting imagine
that now none of this is compatible with
social justice narratives though so you
never hear about it now stores like
Walgreens have learned to just avoid
mentioning organized theft entirely but
that has not appeased activists they
still want you to conclude that there's
a vast conspiracy of foot among various
pharmacies to pull out of black
communities just to spite them you're
supposed to believe that this is why in
just the past two two years uh you know
between Walgreens and Right Aid and CVS
more than 1500 stores have closed
they're all choosing to close profitable
stores and lose money on purpose just
out of their sheer hatred of their Black
customers this is the actual thing that
is being
claimed it's not it's completely insane
but uh it's not just activists in Boston
who are pushing this narrative we're
seeing this denial of reality everywhere
including San Francisco and once again
the NAACP is involved watch rco store
this is like the store for all the
elderly in the neighborhood they can
walk over here there's no stairs easy in
Easy out it's not helping the black
community it's not helping the homeless
it's not helping us at all tonight it's
the very real human cost of a
neighborhood closure the Safeway in San
Francisco's Filmore district is set to
shut down and the community says it's
more than just a bag of groceries
Neighbors in the Filmore and Western
Edition neighborhoods are still angry
tonight saying if this plan goes through
it will have long-term negative
implications on the city's black
community the announced closure for that
store in the Heart of the City on
Webster Street came late Last Week
Tonight ABC7 news reporter J.R stone is
hearing the calls from Neighbors and
Community leaders and brings us this
story in less than 2 months this Safeway
grocery store will close according to
Executives you're gutting it you're just
gutting the neighborhood community
members are outraged saying seniors and
handicapped individuals have been
forgotten about those with Safeway say
they have entered into an agreement to
sell the three plus acres site to a real
estate company for a mixed use
development project to include housing
and commercial retail space they need to
really do things about taking things
from the inner city that we need and
then you're developing housing housing
for who the homeless you need to do
better than that it is a destruction of
a community and those thoughts from Dr
Amos Brown of the
NAACP are echoed by those that live in
the western addition so they're going to
get rid of the business and replace it
with housing probably because housing is
a little tougher to steal I guess but
once again in that news report uh
there's not even a sugges that San
Francisco's policies might be to blame
and that's that's odd given that San
Francisco's policies mirror Boston
according to MBC San Francisco quote
under current state law shoplifting
merchandise valued under $950 is
considered a misdemeanor and often not
investigated could that be the issue
perhaps let's see Chicago Chicago is
another city that stopped Prosecuting
shoplifters unless they steal more than
$1,000 worth of goods and even then uh
cops aren't allowed to Chase CH them how
are things going there well last year
the mayor at the time Lori Lightfoot had
to respond to Walmart's decision to pull
out of the south side of Chicago and
you'll never guess what she said watch
Walmart is moving out closing half of
its stores in Chicago saying they
haven't been profitable in 17 years and
lose millions of dollars a year mayor
Lightfoot calls a decision disappointing
in a statement released today she wrote
in part unceremoniously a abandoning
these neighborhoods will create barriers
to basic needs for thousands of
residents while near-term Arrangements
will be made for workers I fear that
many will find that their long-term
opportunities have been significantly
diminished and Southside elected
officials are also responding issuing a
joint statement and it reads in part
closing four stores in 5 days is
unethical especially since Walmart
claims these stores have not been
profitable since 2006 if Walmart cared
about the community they belong to for
nearly two decades they would have
implemented strategies to combat their
Rising prices the likely root cause of
their decline in earnings the four
stores being closed are the chadam super
center Walmart and the neighborhood
markets in Kenwood Lake View and little
village each store is slated to be
closed by this
Sunday it's really amazing just how
unified the messaging has been on this
issue going back years this is nothing
new and still there is no
self-reflection at all uh there's no
accountability for the people who have
actually made these communities into
dead zones for
businesses the these communities are
actively destroying themselves actively
making their own neighborhoods untenable
for businesses unsafe for people to even
walk down the street at night to go to a
business even if it is open and they
will look anywhere but in the mirror for
people to blame for it so the next time
you hear complaints about food deserts
or Pharmacy deserts keep in mind that
this is what's causing the problem it's
a it's a systemic issue plaguing every
city that's implemented the the Bold
experiment that Boston launched back in
2019 and they will also tell you it's a
systemic issue but but what they're
missing is that this is the systemic
issue so now one of two outcomes is
possible either this experiment can
finally end and we can enforce the law
and people living in these black
communities can get their prescriptions
and their
groceries or these residents can
continue to vote for politicians who
will only make the problem progressively
worse who are promising to make it
worse and these communities can continue
victimizing themselves by constantly
pillaging and stealing from their own
businesses until elderly women are quite
literally dying in the streets because
they can't get their
medication those are the choices it's
clear what the NAACP and corporate press
want
and unless these communities start
taking some
responsibility that's exactly what
they'll get thanks for checking out this
video If You' like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts